okay let's move on now to the possible
escalation with Iran Donald Trump is
straight-up threatening war crimes
against Iran on Twitter he's doing it
casually he's not trying to hide it
let's look at the declaration this was
made of course on Twitter which has
become strangely normal in 2020 under
Donald Trump not only his policy
communicated on Twitter but also threats
of war crimes are communicated on
twitter twitter donald trump saying
quote iran is talking very boldly about
targeting certain USA assets as revenge
for our ridding the world of their
terrorist leader who had just killed an
american and badly wounded many others
not to mention all of the people he had
killed over his lifetime including
recently hundreds of Iranian protesters
he was already attacking our embassy in
preparing for additional hits in other
locations Iran has been nothing but
problems for many years let this serve
as a warning that if Iran strikes any
Americans or American assets we have
targeted 52 Iranian sites representing
the 52 American hostages taken by Iran
many years ago some at a very high level
and important to Iran and the Iranian
culture and those targets and Iran
itself will be hit very fast and very
hard the USA wants no more threats
that's a war crime okay targeting sites
of cultural importance to Iran it's not
open to interpretation we criticized
Isis for doing it there is a widely
sourced Wikipedia article where there
are lists of mosques and libraries and
ancient and medieval sites churches
monasteries all sorts of sites that Isis
destroyed and when they do it we are
very clear these are war crimes they
can't do this we must stop them and then
our president threatens to do the exact
same thing casually on Twitter the
president is tweeting out that he will
commit war crimes on Twitter and nearly
half the country pretends this as normal
there have actually been convictions on
war crimes charges for intentionally
destroying cultural sites ahmad al Faqih
al mahdi was tried at the International
Criminal Court in The Hague
Netherlands for the destruction of
historic mausoleums in the Malian desert
of Timbuktu and mati ultimately pleaded
guilty it is trumped looking to be both
impeached and a tried at the hague and
now an american president being
convicted of war crimes is of course not
likely george w bush good a good
candidate for war crimes charges nothing
happened nothing is going to happen it
is hard to believe but increasingly iran
seems to have the lee legal and moral
high ground here trump with the
unauthorized assassination followed by
threatening war crimes the deliberate
destruction of cultural sites trump up
pulling out of the Iran nuclear deal
without Iran having done anything it's
crazy because we share with the audience
I mean many concerns about this
theocratic regime in Iran which I have
opposed for you know publicly for more
than a decade
it is stunning that we have someone so
depraved and so immoral running our
country that in this narrow set of
circumstances they seem to have the
legal and moral high ground now one
other note on this I hope to have time
to talk about this later this week this
entire thing reeks of evangelical
Christianity in its underlying notion
because again attacking Muslim cultural
sites going after an a regime even if
it's by proxy that evangelical
Christians see is the bad one you know
the evangelical Christians have this
thing where even though many of them are
inherently anti-semitic they are often
very Pro Jewish because they see
supporting Jews as maybe a way to get
the second coming of prey I mean it's
crazy right it's completely bonkers but
it leads to many evangelicals supporting
Jews even if in a way that many Jews are
not that interested in in in having that
support certainly I would fall under
that umbrella the American Christian
Right is absolutely licking their chops
over the possibility of war with Iran
and a lot of this stuff reeks of
evangelical Christianity we'll see if we
have time for that maybe Wednesday on
the program
tomorrow that use day show is already
almost full because so much is going on
we will have continued coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram page
with nearly 25,000 of our viewers and
listeners now following our content
there david pakman show on Instagram
while you're there follow me at David
Pakman as well